>> Vic Gundotra: and the movie will go ahead
and start.
Matt, don't watch the movie. Let's come back.
Let me show you another ad format.
This is also an expandable ad format, but in this case
this expandable ad format has --
I'm sorry, in this case -- I jumped ahead
of you. Let's go back to the other one.
In this case I am going to show you a very
popular ad format that has been testing incredibly
well. This is a click-to-call ad.
In this case we are leveraging the fact that
the user has given us permission to use their
location. We know that they are in San Francisco,
and DirecTV would like to make a special offer
to customers in San Francisco and they have
a new click-to-call option. So simply clicking
on that button on that ad allows the customer
to make that phone call to DirecTV, and that's
incredibly valuable.
Let me talk about another format. This is
an expandable format with a clever twist.
Matt, expand that one out. It includes a map
and directions and click-to-call. Isn't that
great? That's a new format that will become
shortly available as well.
Okay. Finally, let me show what you I meant
when I said open to innovation.
This is the weather.com application, and they
are using the industry standard DoubleClick
software to serve this ad from Google.
The ad is at the bottom.
Now, when Matt clicks on that ad, you get
a full screen immersive ad, and it's a pretty
amazing ad. It's got trailers and TV spots
and galleries. Not only does it have a bunch
of media you can interact with, look at the
bottom there. The bottom has the ability for
you to tap directly into fandango to purchase
movie tickets.
But do you know what the kicker is of what
you are seeing? It's not a Google ad. You
are seeing an immersive ad format delivered
by a great advertising company called MediaLabs.
But because the advertiser -- excuse me the,
ISB, the developer used DoubleClick to serve
the ads, DoubleClick is open to have any ads
show up. And that's what it means to be open.
That we serve the most relevant ad to the
user, sometimes from Google, sometimes not,
but you the developer and the publisher have
the choice.
If would you like to learn more about our
advertising solutions, we encourage you to
go to google.com/mobileads.
And we are opening up AFMA, AdSense for Mobile
Apps, to everybody at the conference, all
5,000 of you.
And we're going to sweeten the deal a little
bit.
If you go sign up, we will give you $100 free
advertising credit to start learning the system
and advertise your apps in the Android Marketplace.
So, please, go try that out.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: One of the most powerful ways
to demonstrate what I talked about at the
beginning, that innovation comes from all
levels of the stack, is to highlight one of
my favorite devices.
This is the device by HTC.
It's the EVO device.
Now, there are several things I love about
this device.
One thing I love about the device is, its
absolutely gorgeous 4.3-inch screen.
I also love how fast it is.
I love the great work HTC has done to add
value.
I love the Sprint network.
It's a 4G network.
You know what a 4G network can do?
It can give you a peak of 10 megabits per
second.
Imagine what you can watch on this device
at 10 megabits per second.
I love the fact that this device has a great
little stand.
You can set it on the desk, or if you're on
an airplane, just set it right there and watch
your content.
It's got a great battery.
It's got HDMI output.
It's got a camera that's 8 megapixels and
that will do 720p HD video recording.
And you know what I love most about this device?
Is that in partnership with Sprint and HTC,
Google is going to make this device available
to every one of you today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Now, for those of you who
are watching on YouTube, I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Remember to register next
year, quickly.
I think you're going to love that device.
We ask you to do two things.
Number one, don't run out right now.
After the keynotes are over, we're going to
make it available all day until 6:00 p.m.
So you'll have plenty of time to get this
device and really get to see the latest in
Android innovation.
Number two thing we're going to ask.
Thank you for supporting Android.
Thank you for voting on the side of openness
and choice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Please keep building those
great apps.
Now, we're at the halfway point this morning.
We're not done yet.
If you'd like to see the next step in the
evolution of Android and where we're about
to go next, hang tight.